hey folks welcome to the cute Woodland
creatures edition of my precon reviews a
plurality of my patrons thought I should
look at the group hug precon and in this
video I'm going to accomplish a simple
set of tasks I'm going to lay out what I
think this deck is trying to do I'm
going to describe what I like about the
deck and finally I'm going to talk about
what I dislike about it and what changes
I'd make to fix the things I dislike
with that in mind let's Jump Right In
the commander for this deck is The
Honorable M bumbleflower and the first
thing I note here is that her effect is
quite cool and unique just the line
whenever you cast a spell Target
opponent draws a card is wild part of
what lets me consider this a group hug
commander of sorts is the sheer amount
of value you can give to your opponents
there are General politics commanders
like Brina and 2023 Roco that passively
offer opponents resources but have a
built-in way to twist things back in
your favor but with M bumbleflower
you're actively handing your opponent
cards when you cast spells and if you
don't cast exactly two spells per turn
she gives your opponents more cards than
she gives you the second spell Clause
gives you cards when the ability
triggers for the second time each turn
and this really hones the blue identity
of the card you want to cast two spells
per turn unless you just love giving
your opponents cards in the deck list we
can see a number of things that fit in
with what this Commander is doing for
one there are a fair number of decently
chunky beaters most of which would enjoy
being given plus one plus1 counters and
flying a lot of these utilize plus one
plus1 counters in some way and to go
with this we can see a handful of other
cards with some sort of counter
synergies in addition to the plus one
plus1 counter beats there is some degree
of giving other players resources
present as you might expect for a duck
labeled group hug there are five cards
that utilize Bloom's gift mechanic where
a spell can have an additional effect if
an opponent is offered some sort of
resource there are also 11 other cards
I'd describe as Huggy and six cards that
are vaguely political in some capacity
though the line between these two
categories I've constructed is a bit
fuzzy there are also other cards whose
effect depends on the actions of your
opponents and you could argue that these
are political though this deck is
relatively Beatdown oriented so I'm not
convinced it will be easy to talk
opponents into feeding these results May
Vary basically it seems like this deck
is looking to gradually develop beaters
and value engines while currying favor
with various opponents right up until it
starts to snowball out of control and
can drop the friendly pretexts so that's
the deck but what do I think about what
this deck is doing well I'll start with
what I like and there's actually quite a
lot of that this deck broadly has a
decent card quality a focused enough
plan to win and good amounts of
different types of support cards there
are several quite decent quality beaters
and M bumbleflower is solid for purposes
of amplifying and pushing through damage
for both these and the cards that are
more in the realm of support creatures
side note I find the aesthetic contrast
between psychosis crawler and the rest
of this deck very funny the plus one
plus1 counter package of this deck
though not super wide has some real
Allstars in it there are several
different threats that grow over time
and among the handful of counter Synergy
pieces rishar Pima Renegade is a pretty
sweet ramp tool and coloni and Hydra is
a counter pumping bomb that will run
away with games if left unchecked the
deck will likely be able to ically
navigate through the game using its
Commander offering some opponents
resources while beating down others with
its Suite of growing threats as I
mentioned earlier the quantities of
support cards here are also quite decent
there are 14 cards that categorizes ramp
and 15 cards that categorizes draw and
these should prepare the deck decently
well to accelerate into a game plan and
keep up momentum even if the deck hits
some setbacks I play tested this deck a
decent number of times and the average
curve out that this deck manages is far
better than in either of the other
precons I've looked at the deck is able
to ramp build Resources with the
commander and set up value engines with
quite a decent degree of consistency
obviously when I'm play testing the deck
I'm kind of abstracting away the cards
that opponents are being given and I
like to think that this is reasonable
enough a lot of EDH games will have one
or two players who are lagging behind a
bit for one reason or another and while
giving these players resources doesn't
necessarily come at no cost the gameplay
cost will be lower than the cost of
giving all opponents resources for that
reason I mostly think about this
resource donation as being probably not
an issue as long as this deck is
meaningfully progressing its own game
plan at the same time while you could
reasonably argue that this means the
deck should be held to a slightly higher
bar than some other precons in terms of
how it plays it most likely passes even
that bar as well this is just a deck
that plays pretty smoothly a big part of
this is likely the Mana base the Mana
base of this deck is pretty similar to
the Mana base of the Outlaws at Thunder
Junction in precon I looked at a few
months back which is to say it has a
healthy land count and a really robust
amount of color fixing that results in
quite healthy symbol counts now this
isn't at no cost of the 38 lands nine
always enter tapped and seven sometimes
do and I'd guess that these two figures
average out to a roughly oneir tap land
quantity while this is a bit higher than
most players will want long term it's
far from a terrible starting point and
this tapland density doesn't feel
particularly bad in practice in addition
in the lens of considering this precon
as a product giving players more fixing
lands to work with is undoubtedly a good
thing even if it means the deck includes
tap lands that might later get cut
finally this deck has an adequate amount
of ways to interact with things
opponents are doing this deck has two
counter spells three board wipes five
single Target removal spells and a
smattering of other cards that play
related purposes such as slowing
opponents defending against major Maj
attacks and protecting key pieces now
one of those categories I've been
historically less of a fan of I find
that space dedicated to defensive spells
would often be better allocated on
actual removal or on things that push a
player's own game plan and I will be
cutting a couple defensive cards from
this deck kind of but this deck's plan
of building large evasive threats means
that life total races won't be an
uncommon situation and having a fog
around in that case might be quite
helpful the X politic iCal tools namely
the commander also give it a decent
option for negotiating with opponents
and avoiding pressure if it seems worth
the price of an opponent having some
cards I can see the appeal of this
deck's political and defensive elements
and I imagine they work decently in
tandem with the deck's more concrete
removal for keeping the game under
control all right it's time to get into
what I dislike about this precon and
also what I Chang to help it out with
those things I mentioned that the Mana
base of the deck reminds me of the otj
ganty precon and there's one other way
that this precon reminds me of that one
in the video where I reviewed the ganty
deck I highlighted that it feels like
the deck list was designed to be a
generic theft deck rather than a semi
theft deck tailored to what ganty does
this pron is similar in that it seems
like Wizards of the Coast added a bunch
of group hug stuff to this precon
because the commander does something
vaguely group hugy but miss bumbleflower
is not a generic group hug Commander no
snail's theory of optimal Bumble flower
dictates that I want to be sharing card
draw with my weakest opponent maybe
playing politics with it here and there
and also making optimal usage of the
plus one plus one counters and flying
that M bumbleflower gives me in addition
a lot of the group hug elements
currently in the deck don't even feel
like they play that nicely with the rest
of what the deck is doing basically what
I dislike about this deck is that it's a
bit unfocused including lots of stuff
that is outside what I believe the deck
wants to be a high velocity politics
heavy plus one plus one counter beat
down deck
now I understand if somebody wants to
play harder into the group hug elements
since group hug is precons don't come
that often but in my mind there's just
not enough to work with here for that I
will preserve the group hug element on
some level though in that I don't feel
the need to prevent or take advantage of
the cards that M bumbleflower gives my
opponents they're allowed to have a
little gift another thing that might be
nice is making the deck slightly lower
curved to allow for double spelling with
Miss bumbleflower earlier in the game
as the current deck is a bit High curved
for my taste overall I'm going to make
20 card swaps and all of these will be
done with a precon budget in mind so I'm
not going to add anything over $3 and
I'm going to try to end up at a lower
overall price for the deck with that in
mind I'm going to start by cutting some
of the hugger elements of this deck I
like the idea of extra land plays in the
deck but I don't really want my
opponents to have extra land plays if
they're going to be getting fed cards by
me so I choose to swap out about rights
of flourishing for Wayward swordtooth
and gerer ory for case of the locked Hot
House case is a really powerful card in
general and sword tooth is a nice option
as a creature to give flying once m
bumbleflower is in play I'm also
choosing to cut tenuous truce and
intellectual offering these cards are
doing something similar to what the
commander is doing but the rate on the
cards per Mana just isn't that great on
either of these quain and salala
likewise get cut because I like being
able to choose which of my opponents fed
cards if one of my opponents is ahead I
want to be able to avoid giving them
extra resources while still being able
to utilize my cards another type of card
I choose to cut is cards that cost too
much Mana since I'm trying to drop the
Mana curve octamer is a funny card but
this isn't really a token deck and five
Mana is just too much to pay for some
vanilla stats another cut is Coveted
Jewel it's a funny card but this deck
doesn't have enough ways of preventing
opponents from snagging it and when it
does get taken they don't even need to
pay that expensive six Mana upfront like
I did most other Cuts I made were cards
that just don't do enough bloodroot
Apothecary though it's pre-selling for
upwards of $10 seems highly mediocre to
me as anti-t treasure Tech opponents can
still afford to crack a few treasures at
a table without other poison and then
the rest can be saved for after the
Apothecary is off the board I'll take a
mangle horn over this any day of the
week now a cut that truly pains me is
Jolly Geral this card is extremely cute
but the deck simply doesn't have enough
gift cards to justify its inclusion and
even if I added a few more I'm still not
convinced it would be preferable to a
better two drop another cut is
hoofprints of the Stag this is a decent
incremental value piece if it's played
early but it's a very dead draw later in
the game Trisa deile is another card I
opted to cut this deck wants some number
of no maximum Hand siiz cards but the
deck already has several other ones and
this card just doesn't offer enough
outside of that to warrant keeping it in
in my opinion what goes in in place of
these cards Beyond The Replacements I
already mentioned a big area is plus one
plus1 counter synergies a lot of these
are reasonably basic conclave Mentor is
a bear that amplifies counters dusk
Legion dualist is a bear that's a draw
engine benic biomancer is a similar card
for one Mana that loots instead and Kami
of the whispered hopes is just a
fantastic card well worth the $2 or so
price tag a couple others I picked out
that likewise offer a bit of ramp were
incubation Druid and free Strider
Lookout importantly I tried to pick out
stuff that's good in general and
relatively low cost the issue with
picking out big fancy payoff cards is
that opponents can just deny your
commander with removal and then suddenly
you invested heavily in something that
can't actually materialize Kami and
Druid in particular are especially great
because without the commander they're
still manad dorks but with even a single
targeting with M Bumble flower's ability
either of them can suddenly tap for
three whole mana and Kami only goes up
from there there are also a few more
specific cards from Modern Horizons 3
that I added as that was a fantastic set
for plus one plus1 counter synergies
dream tide whale is a card that feels
like it was made for this deck it
proliferates plus one plus one counters
it has a high power for delivering
flying beats and this is a deck that
wants to double spell anyway so the
whale should be sticking around
Evolution witness is another pretty
sweet card it's not going to be wildly
powerful in the early game but later in
the game it can be an Unstoppable
torrent of value the third card from
this set I added is Envoy of the
ancestors and this is my answer to the
question of defensive cards and life
total races just gain some life this
card sets up a player for a truly
impressive quantity of Life gain which
will help when facing off against the
final player and needing to survive long
enough to get the necessary attacks in
to finish them off Beyond these I also
tweaked the interaction Suite A bit I
added negate as a nice general purpose
counter spell to help with avoiding
board wipes and I also swapped out
perplexing test for a slightly weirder 5
Mana instant broker's Confluence this is
a fun package for the deck it can shut
off a problematic ability it can protect
our board without losing the counters
and it can also serve as a sort of
overrun type card if we're going in for
the kill you can always just proliferate
proliferate proliferate finally I also
tweak the Mana base to have more green
Mana since I just cut a bunch of Blue
and White cards and added a bunch of
green ones over overall this precon was
quite solid and I actually considered
changing fewer than my usual 20 cards
for this deck considering that you could
probably drop the number of changes to
10 and still have quite a decent plus
one plus one counter based upgraded pron
but I just felt like taking it all the
way with my changes I didn't talk about
this earlier Beyond gesturing the fact
that a lot of tables will have a player
or two lagging behind but I imagine the
sort of selective hug effect seen on M
bumbleflower is likely an enjoyable
addition for a lot of tables my issue
with symmetrical group hug is that
though it means everybody's deck gets to
do something it often also means that
the player who is getting ahead anyway
gets to have even more Advantage this
more selective method of resource giving
on the other hand can theoretically lead
to more Dynamic games with different
players on a more equal footing to
anybody who has played with this precon
or this Commander in general let me know
if this was your experience because I'm
kind of
curious thanks for watching if you like
what I do here and you want some more of
it you can support me over on patreon I
recently got a new camera lens and I've
started recording these kind of random
face cam videos of ideas that I've had
but that haven't quite made their way
into a video and I'm posting those over
on patreon one that I released a day or
so ago included some thoughts on a bunch
of different Bloom Barrow cards if that
sounds up your alley link is going to be
down in the description